学校が出ていない
実は今次日本はいくつ
多分冬
お正月
クリスマスからお正月が一番
空いてるので
田舎が見られる
ゆっくりと
安子とアメリカを打ちにくるんですか
考えてない
1年に1回はね
ミキと会いましょうっていうことを
言ってたのだけど
今度彼女が来てくれちゃったから
だから今すぐ行かないで
来年にしようかどうしようか
もしかしたら
クリスマスの前に
ちょっと来てもいいしって言ってるんだけど
ルイスはいつ行くんだっけ
26日
今月
そうかじゃあちょっと早すぎるかな
私にはね
どうしようか
次にアミちゃんがもしかしたら来る
だからそしたらアミと一緒にね
帰ってきたらいいんじゃないって言うんだけど
分かんない
アミちゃんいつ頃来るだろう
分かんないね
ちょうどアミも冬だと思う
いや
去年も冬
来たっけ
それと2年前
2年前
冬
うん
ん?
去年夏だった?
来たん?
うん?
えっとアメリカ
ワシントンに来たん?
去年5月ぐらいだったと思う
うん
去年行ったのはいつ頃だかもう忘れちゃった
あの秋だったと思う
うん
やっぱり
お父さん寒いっすか?
大丈夫?
ん?
寒くない?
夏もん
大丈夫です
でもアミちゃんも日本に来たいでしょ?
夏も
うん
ウィキがそう言ってるけどでも分かんないけど
夏色々あって
冬休みが一番
絶対空いてるって分かる感じかな
ルイスさん気をつけてくださいね
気分って
うん
で
今
大丈夫?
私
多分
切った時に
いよたいが
たくさんあった
うん
もう変えるかな
変えるは
多分
大丈夫
えっと
今日は月曜